the AFD had hoped its far-right agenda
would persuade East Germans to put it
first in the event the party came a
close second but more than doubled its
vote in the process and struck deep into
the mainstream parties heartlands I
would have hoped that as the icing on
the cake we would become the strongest
party but this result this exit poll
shows one thing the FT has come to stay
politics without us will no longer be
possible their opponents in Saxony were
the center-right Christian Democrats
who've governed there since 1990 but who
lost more than 80,000 votes to the AFD
and yet still emerged clear in first
place for them there now begins the
difficult process of trying to build a
coalition with parties at the center and
the center-left we did it and this is a
message that we sent from Saxony a large
majority of people want to represent a
state in a positive way and wanted to
achieve things the friendly side of
Saxony has won it was also a difficult
night for the Social Democrats who are
on the center-left of German politics
they've governed Brandenburg ever since
the fall of communism 30 years ago yet
on Sunday they lost votes and were very
nearly beaten by the far-right it was a
tough election campaign it was an
intensive discussion and I would like to
thank all of you that we succeeded in
showing that this state has one party
which people trust and that remains
Brandenburg's SPD one of the key factors
for voters in this election had been
nostalgia thirty years since the fall of
the Berlin Wall
how did people view the past three
decades of democracy and there was the
role of immigration even though these
two states have relatively small
immigrant populations compared to the
rest of the country this result shows
the AFD is now a force to be reckoned
with
across East Germany and although it will
not enter government its presence will
make coalition-building difficult and it
throws up one more central question
with so many voters now deserting the
two main parties how long can their
grand coalition continue at a federal
level
Domenic came aljazeera in brandenburg